it certainly seems that these passages
indicate that Mary Magdalene had a
special role among the disciples as the
foremost one who inherited the true
teachings of Jesus which like we said is
a theme in the Gospel of Mary as well
and while leaving the possibility that
Jesus and her had a romantic
relationship totally open as a
possibility I think we can probably read
this passage in a symbolic way too
indeed in another passage it says quote
people are nourished from the promise of
the Heavenly place if they would be and
there's a gap here from the mouth from
which the word comes they would be
nourished from the mouth and would be
perfect the perfect conceive and give
birth through a kiss that is why we also
kiss each other we conceive from the
grace within each
other here is a clear indication to me
at least that the true teachings of
which the gospel speaks are conceived or
transmitted perhaps in a way through a
kind of sacred kiss